in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Chris
and Andrea are with us hey guys how are
you hey Dave doing great
welcome welcome where do you guys live
Cleveland Ohio and you came all the way
to Nashville to do a debt-free scream
yep
well we're honored to have you thank you
for being here thank you so how much
debt have you paid off how we have paid
off $55,000 Wow good how long did that
take about thirty four months good for
you and range of income during that time
we started off with around ninety ninety
five thousand and now we're making
around 170 whoa what was that big jump I
got a full-time job oh okay all right
what do you do I teach medical students
good for you and what do you do Chris
I'm an electrical engineer okay very
good a wonderful household income
phenomenal what kind of debt was the
$55,000 I was primarily student loans
and credit card debts and one small
medical debt so you're just kind of
normal pretty normal everything
everything but the car dad I mean you
had everything else right yep yeah okay
so how long have you guys been married
it'll be three years in September oh so
that's what started this then it is so
you come back from the honeymoon because
34 months there we go huh
I was actually before the marriage we
got engaged and then we found a church
and then shortly after that they had the
Financial Peace University and then that
was something they really clicked on
like I was getting the message I got to
do this so that's what we did cool so
the engineer wants to go learn how to
handle money nobody shocked about that
Andrea you were you're on board with
that idea I was it was a little more
difficult for me probably but but I was
there okay so yeah you were a little bit
resistant going into the class that
would be normal that would be me yeah
I'll be a lot resistant and so what was
the process what was the feeling and the
thing that happened to you or you're
going through Financial Peace University
me myself I just got this great image
that you know I follow this this is the
way to go this is what we need to do and
you know you were feeling a little more
overwhelmed with what was happening so
for me it was just stay focused this is
something we can do we should kind of
keep plowing on through it and you know
we had her ups and downs but when I was
down she was up when she was down and I
was up and that's how we were able to
get through it so what do you tell
people when they find out you paid off
fifty five thousand dollars worth of
debt Andrea and they ask you how did you
do that when he tell him the secret of
getting out of debt is because you did
it we did and I pretty much tell them
that it was a budget that's it yeah I
mean it was that was what we really had
to do we had to make a decision every
month about how we were going to spend
our money and even the months where we
had to make lower debt payments because
of emergencies we still did it you know
yeah and that we didn't give up during
those months where it didn't work so so
it's it's not a perfect line no you know
33 months especially or 36 for 34 months
during the first 36 months of marriage
it's uh especially during a brand-new
marriage because you're trying to learn
to live together anyway
yeah no I'm trying to learn to further
your life to work and all that kind of
stuff and then on top of that we got all
this money stuff going on yeah so what
was the hardest part for you guys for me
it was letting things that seem big but
weren't emergencies take a backseat so
like you know home improvements anything
around the house that maybe doesn't look
the greatest but it's still functional
we basically have a downstairs that's in
the middle of renovating for the last
two years you know but uh you know you
put that on the you see that for two
years and is just bugging you to get it
done but it's like look that's not the
priority this is the priority you can
live with this mm-hmm you know keep
focused what about you Andrea what was
the hardest part for you I think
sometimes it was um almost a little bit
more of the social pressure you know
hearing family or friends say oh you
should go buy this this is this is on
sale you know you need this but you
don't really need it it's just something
that you want eventually so that it
seems like somebody wants to go out to
eat every night
everything yeah especially when you're
newlywed
I mean it's crazy in it I mean do these
people ever cook I mean it's amazing
so hey well congratulations you guys I'm
very proud of you
what a great way to start your marriage
absolutely incredible how does it feel
uh we're still getting used to it but
you know it feels great when you really
think about it like wow I don't have to
pay that anymore I can use it for just
about anything really it's awesome
how's it feel Andrea it um it makes me
hopeful for our children that's every
time I start thinking about that I get a
little teary that's very cool and you
have one child yes we do him what's his
name
her name is Regan Oh her name okay I'm
sorry all right little baby
yeah all right Oh cute now I see you're
okay yeah I wouldn't have made that
mistake about you Oh cute cute cute all
right fine all right Chris and Andrea
and Regan Cleveland Ohio $55,000 paid
off in 34 months making 90 to 170 a year
count it down let's hear it free scream
three two one
hey yeah that child's whole family tree
has changed cuz her mom and daddy
decided they were gonna get control of
their life very well done I love it so
proud of you guys
excellent job hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show and so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind